For some of us, LinkedIn is a new and
unfamiliar platform.
For others,
you might know it and love it.
Our goal is to make you know and
appreciate the power of LinkedIn.
When I move to the U.S.
from Germany, I did not know what to
put in my English LinkedIn version.
As Germans are generally more private,
I saw filling up my LinkedIn
as a horrible pointless hurdle
that really stretched my limits.
However, after doing some research and
getting more familiar with
the customization options of LinkedIn,
I started to realize that
LinkedIn had a lot of potential.
If used skilfully,
it could give me a lot of
agency in creating my personal brand,
an ideal professional identity.
A LinkedIn profile contains
multiple customizable sections.
You can change the order of those
sections depending on your background
and better convey your
goals to recruiters.
For example,
if you're switching careers completely,
you can make your project section
proceed your work experience.
You could also create your
own professional headline.
This means you can define what you are,
not your current job title.
You can select a professional image of
yourself, allowing you to make a great
professional first impression
before the interview.
You can also
present a compelling summary
statement that frames your story.
This is extremely helpful if you're
changing careers, are new to the field,
or simply have an eclectic background,
like me.
LinkedIn invites you to present a
comprehensive list of your professional
experience with detailed bullets
about what you did at each place.
Finally, with LinkedIn, you can present
information about your passions,
hobbies, causes, and interests
that may not fit on your resume.
If you have a LinkedIn profile,
what parts do you have currently?
Feel free to respond in our forum.